je vais demander tant farida de venir
sur le plateau
mais laquelle
maman maman
les wings
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais
ne jamais faire ça avec ma mère des
jantes izik moi c'est la première fois
qu'elle n'a sûrement pas dit qu'elle le
voit elle est magnifique
[Applaudissements]
cette émission
connu comme nous parler je sais que
c'est également une ex d'elie semoun a
qui a invité farida et aujourd'hui je
peux te le dire je suis peut-être un
petit peu son beau père dont calme-toi
[Rires]
bonsoir farida sa merci l'etl chars dire
déjà que vous êtes magnifique la maman
drive est ici notre vie nos amis les
chiens ne font pas des chats farida
qu'est ce que vous avez à nous dire sur
moi j'ai une grosse charia sayad quand
il avait 10 ans oui qui sait très bien
que j'ai la phobie des déchetteries les
souris souvient des souris et un jour il
m'a mené une souris ils savaient qu'ils
en voulaient pas pour se venger
même plein de crottes non mais complexe
tout à l'heure on a vécu un beau moment
d'émotion
[Musique]
tu avais mis le feu aussi tu te souviens
tu t'amuses et avec un fou là j'étais
dans la khl oui j'ai brûlé la maison
mais ces souris le feu dans la maison ça
fait beaucoup
la serviette en fait sur l'halogène il
vient vers moi y'a le feu il ya le feu
mais en fait je croyais pas mon bac et
notre dame de paris c'est toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est un jeu c'est un tabou qui vous
a piqué je lui laisse en tas avait parlé
d'une synagogue et farida c'est la
première fois que vous mais sur un
plateau oui tout à fait mais vous êtes
fier de lui très toujours en mes parents
vous l'appelez tous les jeux tournent du
côté de ma mère désolé vous l'appelez
tous les jours régulièrement ça va
j'aurais a marqué 12 avril à d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
très